Wie sag ich das jetzt am besten?
Die Affenpocken
gehen gerade erst los.
Spaß, schlechter Witz.
Ist das 'n Witz?
Genau darüber müssen wir
jetzt mal ernsthaft sprechen.
Ich weiß, grade hat niemand Lust,
was über ein neues Virus zu erfahren,
aber durch Verdrängung
werden die Sorgen auch nicht besser.
Wie gefährdet sind Kinder?
Muss man sich impfen lassen?
Sind Affenpocken sexuell übertragbar?
Kann das eine neue Pandemie werden?
Holt euch 'nen Tee,
wir steigen durch.
Ende Mai wurde diese Stellungnahme
zu den Affenpocken veröffentlicht,
an der sich mehrere medizinische
Fachgesellschaften beteiligt haben.
Es wird rasches und konsequentes
Handeln gefordert.
Ich geh das mal mit euch durch
und kommentier's.
Rund 250 bestätigte Fälle weltweit,
steht hier.
Das ist der Stand 24. Mai.
Zum Zeitpunkt dieses Videos,
zwei Wochen später,
sind es schon
mehr als 1.000 Fälle weltweit.
Wobei 1.000 Fälle weltweit
dürften uns seit Corona
nicht wirklich schocken. Oder?
Grundsätzlich
sind Infektionskrankheiten
nicht gleich Grund zum Schock.
Die meisten von uns
haben ein Immunsystem,
das gut funktioniert.
Wir haben Impfungen,
wir haben Medikamente.
Sus wird's ... Sorry, ich hab
noch nie das Wort "sus" verwendet
und fühl mich grad wie 'n Boomer.
Liebe Kinder,
bitte schreibt in die Kommentare,
ob Viren auch sus sein können oder
ob ich's nie wieder sagen soll.
Also, verdächtig wird's,
wenn Krankheiten neu sind.
Also, entweder wenn sie
wirklich neu sind, wie SARS-CoV-2,
oder wenn sie sich neu verhalten,
wie die Affenpocken.
Neu bedeutet nämlich,
dass unser Immunsystem
damit nichts anfangen kann
und dass wir wahrscheinlich
auch nicht oder nicht ausreichend
Medikamente oder Impfungen haben.
Und dann kann das
gegebenenfalls gefährlich werden.
Was genau ist also
an den Affenpocken neu?
Eins nach dem anderen.
Affenpocken sind nicht zu verwechseln
mit den "Menschenpocken",
also mit den ganz normalen Pocken.
Die sind zwar verwandt,
aber die normalen Pocken sind
viel gefährlicher und tödlicher.
Die Pocken gelten dank
einer großen, globalen Impfkampagne
seit 1980 als ausgerottet.
Die Affenpocken wurden 1958
im Labor bei Affen nachgewiesen,
daher der Name.
Eigentlich ist das Virus aber
bei Nagetieren zu Hause.
Also, sinnvollerweise müssten
die Nage- ... Nagerpocken heißen.
Wir haben's also mit einer Zoonose
zu tun, mit einer Krankheit,
die von Tier zu Mensch
oder andersrum übertragbar ist.
Dieses Überspringen
von Tier auf Mensch
beobachten wir vor allem
in einigen afrikanischen Länder.
Dort gibt es immer mal wieder
lokale Ausbrüche,
weil die Viren dort endemisch sind.
Genauer gesagt gibt es
zwei Abstammungslinien des Virus.
Eine ist in Westafrika endemisch,
die andere in Zentralafrika.
Die westafrikanische Variante
verläuft normalerweise mild.
Das ist die, die jetzt auch bei uns
und in anderen Ländern
angekommen ist.
Dementsprechend sind bisher
auch alle bekannt gewordenen Fälle
ohne Komplikationen verlaufen.
Neu ist jetzt aber,
dass doch so viele Fälle gleichzeitig
in nicht-endemischen Ländern
auftreten
ohne erkennbare Verbindung
zu Westafrika.
Das Virus scheint sich
stärker zu verbreiten als sonst.
Warum?
Option A: Unsere Immunität
hat sich verändert.
Hat sie tatsächlich auch.
Die Pocken und die Affenpocken
sind verwandt genug,
sodass jemand,
der gegen Pocken geimpft ist,
auch einen gewissen Schutz gegen
Affenpocken hat - Kreuzimmunität.
Da die Pocken aber
erfolgreich ausgerottet wurden,
wird inzwischen
nicht mehr gegen sie geimpft.
Also, ich als Baujahr '87,
sus, wurd nicht geimpft.
Ich hab keine Pockenimmunität
und viele andere Menschen
auf der Welt auch nicht mehr.
Option B: Das Virus
hat sich verändert. Möglich.
Wir wissen ja von Corona, dass sich
Viren verändern und anpassen können.
Affenpockenviren
sind jetzt DNA-Viren.
Die können nicht ganz so schnell
und häufig mutieren wie RNA-Viren,
zu denen Coronaviren gehören.
Das verringert
die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
aber schließt nicht aus,
dass sich das Affenpockenvirus
an den Menschen besser angepasst hat
oder noch anpassen wird.
Option C:
Unser Verhalten hat sich geändert.
Vielleicht gibt's jetzt irgendwo
Kontakte zu Nagetieren
oder anderen Überträgern,
die es vorher so nicht gab.
Überhaupt trägt
menschliches Verhalten
zum allgemeinen Pandemierisiko bei.
Klimawandel, Abholzen von Wäldern.
Laut diese Studie treffen
auf der Suche nach neuen Lebensräumen
immer häufiger Spezies aufeinander,
die sich sonst
nie oder kaum begegnet sind.
Gelegenheit,
um Krankheitserreger auszutauschen.
Das kann auch
bei uns Menschen dazu führen ...
"Dass wir immer häufiger
mit Wildtierarten in Kontakt kommen,
weil wir die Ökosysteme
dramatisch verändert haben."
"Vor allem mit Fledermäusen
haben wir viel engere Begegnungen."
"Diese Tiere tragen
eine Reihe von Viren in sich,
die wir noch nie zuvor
gesehen haben."
"Sie können von einer Fledermaus
auf eine menschliche Population
überspringen."
"Wir haben es bei SARS, MERS
und COVID-19 gesehen."
Okay, alle drei genannten Optionen
können auch gleichzeitig auftreten.
Warum genau die Affenpocken
sich jetzt gerade häufen,
wissen wir also derzeit noch nicht.
Wir wissen nur, dass sie sich häufen.
Und das ist ein Problem.
Wie gesagt,
die Affenpocken sind bisher mild.
Es könnte schlimmer sein.
Aber können sie uns
deswegen egal sein?
Nein.
Es gab Todesfälle
bei früheren Ausbrüchen,
auch bei der milderen
westafrikanischen Variante.
Man kann zwar nicht alles
auf Deutschland direkt übertragen.
Zum Beispiel wurde auch
von einer erhöhten Sterblichkeit
von Kindern berichtet.
Gleichzeitig ist
die Kindersterblichkeit
in den betroffenen Regionen
allgemein höher als hier.
Sodass man so keine gezielte Aussage
über die Gefahr
von Affenpocken treffen kann.
Unabhängig vom Alter
hängt die Sterblichkeit
auch von der Qualität
der medizinischen Versorgung ab,
die hierzulande zum Glück hoch ist.
Man muss aber trotzdem
davon ausgehen,
dass immungeschwächte Menschen
während einer Chemotherapie
oder nach einer Organtransplantation
ein erhöhtes Risiko
für einen schweren Verlauf haben.
Auch die Pusteln,
die sich bei Affenpocken bilden,
sind nicht immer harmlos.
Sie können nicht nur
bleibende Narben hinterlassen,
sie können sich auch in den Augen
bilden und diese beschädigen.
Und es gäbe die theoretische Gefahr,
dass das Virus hier endemisch,
also heimisch wird
und wir immer wieder
Ausbrüche hätten.
Entweder indem es sich besser
auf uns Menschen als Wirt anpasst,
oder indem es auf eine hier
heimische Tierart überspringt.
Ob's in Europa
überhaupt eine Tierart gibt,
bei der sich dieses Virus
langfristig festsetzen könnte,
ist bisher nicht bekannt.
Aber man muss es auch nicht
drauf ankommen lassen, ne?
Kurz gesagt, es wäre besser,
wenn sich dieses Virus nicht
unkontrolliert ausbreiten würde.
Deswegen sollten wir entschlossen,
schnell und abgestimmt handeln.
Die medizinischen Fachgesellschaften
schlagen drei Maßnahmen vor.
Erstens:
Was heißt das?
Erst mal:
Zu den frühen Symptomen gehören
Fieber, Kopfschmerzen,
geschwollene Lymphknoten.
Ein paar Tage später
typischerweise Ausschlag,
oft im Mund und Genitalbereich.
Erst als flache, rote Flecken,
dann als eitrige Pusteln.
Bei Verdacht sofort zum Arzt gehen.
Außerdem:
Affenpocken sind nicht nur,
aber in erster Linie,
durch engen Körperkontakt
übertragbar.
Besonders ansteckend
ist der Hautausschlag,
der anfangs auch nicht
so besonders auffällig sein muss.
Es ist also zum Glück
nicht wie bei Corona,
dass man schon singen in
geschlossenen Räumen vermeiden muss,
sondern eher wechselnde Sexualpartner
oder das Teilen
von Betten und Kleidung.
Momentan stecken sich
überproportional Männer an,
die Sex mit Männern haben.
Die medizinische Gruppenbezeichnung
"MSM" - men who habe sex with men -
umfasst Schwule, Bisexuelle und
Männer, die Sex mit Männern haben.
Das ist erst mal 'ne wichtige Info,
'ne wichtige Korrelation,
die man kennen sollte,
um sich gegebenenfalls
vor einem erhöhten Infektionsrisiko
zu schützen.
Gleichzeitig muss man verstehen,
Korrelation
ist nicht gleich Kausalität.
Als schwuler Mann hab ich
ein statistisch erhöhtes Risiko,
mich anzustecken.
Aber meine sexuelle Orientierung
ist nicht die Ursache dafür.
Viren wissen ja nichts
von sexueller Orientierung.
Sie übertragen sich da,
wo Kontakt ist.
Im Fall Affenpocken
bei engem Körperkontakt,
egal ob sexuell homo oder hetero
oder auch nicht-sexuell.
Kampfsportturniere, wechseln
von Trikots nach Fußballspielen,
Kitagruppen.
Das wären auch
geeignete Infektionsherde.
Und wenn man die aktuellen Ausbrüche
nicht schnell
und entschlossen eindämmt,
wäre es naheliegend, dass solche Orte
als "Risikoorte" folgen.
Dass Sex bei Affenpocken
gerade so im Fokus steht,
ergibt sich aus einem viel
allgemeineren Zusammenhang.
Nämlich, je enger der Körperkontakt,
desto höher das Risiko.
Und ... viel enger als bei Sex
wird Körperkontakt halt selten.
Die Affenpocken werden nicht
als klassisch sexuell
übertragbare Krankheit verstanden.
Doch dieses Missverständnis
setzt sich grade fest, fürchte ich,
weil ich auch immer wieder
Sachen höre wie:
"Ungeschützter Sex sei ein Risiko."
Was bei Affenpocken
jetzt aber erst mal Quatsch ist.
Ja, Affenpocken konnten teilweise
im Sperma von Infizierten
nachgewiesen werden.
Das kann auch
bei anderen Viren passieren.
Das Virus verteilt sich
bei einer Infektion
übers Blut im ganzen Körper.
Aber da wir ja wissen,
dass enger Körperkontakt an sich
schon zu Ansteckung führt,
ist Spermakontakt
vielleicht ein Zusatzrisiko,
aber sicherlich nicht das einzige.
Risikoaufklärung ist hier tricky.
Ähnlich wie damals bei HIV,
also damals wurde entweder AIDS als
"Schwulenkrankheit" stigmatisiert,
oder, im anderen Extrem, der
Zusammenhang komplett verschwiegen.
Entweder aus Angst
vor Stigmatisierung
oder - in konservativeren,
homophoben Kreisen -
um so zu tun, als gäbe es
weder Schwule noch die Krankheit.
Also, ähnliche Fehler
in er Kommunikation
sollten wir diesmal vermeiden.
Zurück zum Ausbruchsmanagement.
Das Gute ist, man muss jetzt nicht,
so wie bei Corona, Angst haben,
dass man während der Isolation
innerhalb eines Haushalts
dasselbe Zimmer mit Aerosolen füllt.
Die Isolation
dürfte sehr wirksam sein,
um Infektionsketten zu durchbrechen.
Zweite Maßnahme,
die hier vorgeschlagen wird,
ist die Vorbereitung
einer Impfstrategie.
Nicht flächendeckend,
das braucht's nicht,
so wie wir die Affenpocken
gerade verstehen.
Aber bei den Jüngeren,
die keine Pockenimpfung hatten,
könnten Ringimpfungen sinnvoll sein.
Dabei werden gezielt
nur die Kontaktpersonen
um einen Infizierten herum geimpft.
Praktisch ist nämlich,
dass Pockenimpfstoffe
noch kurz nach der Infektion
wirken können,
also auch noch
in der frühen Inkubationszeit
gegeben werden können.
Gibt's denn Impfstoffe? Ja.
In der EU gibt es
einen modernen Pockenimpfstoff,
also gegen die normalen Pocken.
In den USA ist er aber auch explizit
gegen Affenpocken zugelassen.
Deutschland könnte da nachziehen.
Die dritte Maßnahme sind Medikamente.
Affenpocken heilen normalerweise
innerhalb von zwei bis vier Wochen
von alleine ab.
Aber sollte es doch mal
einen schweren Verlauf geben,
gibt's das Antiaffenpocken-Medikament
Tecovirimat.
Ein zweites Medikament
ist zumindest in den USA
gegen die normalen Pocken zugelassen
und wirkt im Tierversuch
auch gegen Affenpocken.
So viel zur Stellungnahme.
Verlinken wir euch auch unten.
Also, können die Affenpocken
eine neue Pandemie werden?
Wenn ihr unter Pandemie
so was wie Corona versteht,
dann nein.
Dafür gibt's momentan
keinen Grund zur Annahme.
Die Krankheit ist bekannt,
sie breitet sich langsamer aus
und nur durch engen Körperkontakt.
Wir haben Impfungen und Medikamente.
Aber es erledigt sich
halt nicht von allein,
sondern erfordert
schnelles und konsequentes Handeln.
Es wär jetzt echt megadumm,
darüber die Kontrolle zu verlieren.
Nicht nur, weil man
Schäden und seltene Todesfälle
mit verhältnismäßig wenig Aufwand
vermeiden kann,
sondern auch, weil man letztendlich
mit jeder Infektion
'nem Virus die Chance gibt,
zu mutieren.
Laut dem Global Virome Project,
einer Forschungsinitiative,
deren Ziel es ist,
zukünftige Pandemien
proaktiv statt reaktiv zu bekämpfen,
gibt es noch über 500.000
unentdeckte zoonotische Viren,
also Viren, die von Tieren
auf Menschen überspringen können.
Die können harmlos sein.
Die können
auch schlimmer sein als Corona.
Es ist Russisch Roulette.
Also, man kann immer Pech haben.
Aber indem wir Menschen
den Klimawandel vorantreiben,
Lebensräume zerstören,
Wildtiere jagen,
Nutztiere auf kleinstem Raum halten
und so weiter,
drehen wir quasi
immer öfter und schneller
an der Revolvertrommel
und fordern das Pech geradezu heraus.
Angst und Panik
ist natürlich nie sinnvoll.
Aber ernst nehmen sollten wir
die Gefahr
einer zweiten Pandemie unbedingt.
Wenn nicht durch Affenpocken,
dann halt durch eine der anderen
500.000 unentdeckten Viren.
Krieg ich jetzt noch die Kurve
zu 'nem gut gelaunten Ende?
Nee, aber das ist
ja auch nicht mein Job.
Ihr habt ja nicht
für gute Laune abonniert.
Ich will euch aber
ein neues funk-Format vorstellen:
"Atlas", da kriegt ihr jede Woche
Geschichten aus dem Ausland.
Hier geht's
um Drogenkartelle in Mexiko
und wie sie ihren Nachwuchs
über TikTok rekrutieren.
Schaut da unbedingt vorbei.
Gebt dem Team gern
'n bisschen Liebe und Rückenwind.
Und bei uns nicht vergessen,
auf die Glocke zu drücken,
um nichts zu verpassen.
Man weiß nie, wann es kommt.
Bis dahin: Bleibt sicher.